[Music]
[Music]
sauce instead of association with just
dead deer mowing our sport with scooter
we just had the range of riding and
young member trying out the scooter runs
sort of just yeah showing how the dogs
can pull you down the trail and trying
out what the infant classes are
[Music]
hi I'm Marie mell Mariska I have a
German Shepherd dog is five years of age
and I've taught him to detect
hydrocarbons such as fuels petrels oils
in any other lubricants myths we can
pick them up at very very high levels
other than the human nose it can now we
have 20 million receptors they have 450
million receptors so it's incredible
what they can pick on and here today as
some cotton buds with a tiny little bit
of octane 91 octane and this has been
sitting in here for about a couple of
weeks now so it gets old but still
absorbs so what I'll do is I'll go and
hide it you'll see here I'm not touching
with my hands to give any human scent on
it so it's just all to do with the
carbon so I'll go hide that sunny
good boy where you got yes good
[Music]